THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THURSDAY MARCH FIFTEENTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. COPIES BE ADVICE
ON THE AUDIO VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS GREEN BAY
HAS ALSO BEEN TELEVISED. AMEND
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY.
HERE CUNNINGHAM ALLEN
BORROW CARILLO.
PRESIDENT
TORONTO HERE. FRIEDMAN GRAYSON
HERE AS AREA STALINISTS WASN'T
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND YOU HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOTION LOOK SENATE
JENNIFER MOVED BY MISTER CELSUS
SECULAR I MISS WALDRON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM ALLEN. BROKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE NOSE AREA SOLID SIDE
DOLLARS I AND WALDRON.
ORGANIZED.
SO THE MOTIONS TRASH AND WHICH
WAS PLEASE RETURN TAKING.
RIGHT. EVERY AYE PUBLIC